he heard you he's like what did he just  say about me maybe you don't  watch me so look at orlando  warriors had a 13-point lead this game  has flipped 16 points  [Applause]  ennis trying to stay with curry and  steph dropping in the three  goodness that's sidestep ennis is right  there  but because he's a right-hand shooter  steph had just enough space to get that  one off  steph's taking nothing but threes he's  five of it watch steph  coming off of this the rip through just  using as his  momentum against him then shake your  head this man can't guard me  what's he thinking look at the  separation he got  and we saw him before the game we were  right here he was working on that very  move with q